la grande force de ce smartphone c7
écran 21/9 là vous êtes sur une vidéo
sur youtube puis complètement optimisé
pour l'avenir des zooms et zoomer on est
directement sur du 21 9ème et voyez on
un format très allongée très long qui
donne l l'immersion là par exemple vous
avez gravity au format 21 9ème l'âge une
image qui est complètement
[Musique]
je viens vous parler aujourd'hui d'un
téléphone avec un format très
particulier qui est le seul enfin un des
seuls smartphones sur le marché n'a pas
beaucoup à proposer un format très
particulier format 21/9 c'est le sony
xperia 10 plus cette année au mwc
souvenirs présenté plusieurs smartphones
et là des gens je vous ai présenté il ya
quelques jours il ya le xperia 10 6 est
le xperia 10 plus et le xperia one on
testera un peu plus tard et pour
l'instant je voulais vous présenter ce
xperia 10 plus parce que il a un format
qui est très intéressant c'est le format
cinémascope ces formats cinéma c'est le
format 21/9 c'est très long c'est très
allongée par rapport à ce qu'on retrouve
sur d'autres smartphones format 19/9 19
points 5/9 landa 21/9 on a vraiment une
sensation de regarder un film d'horreur
du cinéma et c'est vraiment le le
créneau sur lequel est positionné sony
on le voit sur leurs différents
smartphones on l'a vu notamment l'année
dernière avec le ixe aide 3 sony c'est
une entreprise qui est colossal avec
plusieurs milieux yann cinéma il ya
l'audio il ya les smartphones il y à la
télé enfin y'a plein plein plein plein
de choses et sony a beaucoup de
savoir-faire sony malgré tout du mal
avec ses smartphones et du mal à
s'imposer dans le domaine de la
téléphonie et c'est vraiment dommage
parce qu'ils ont énormément de savoir
faire on a déjà pu voir l'année dernière
avec le higgs est de 3 et continue le
confirmer cette année avec ces nouveaux
modèles format 21/9 ils ont une maîtrise
au niveau des écrans ils ont une
maîtrise au niveau du cinéma
alors c'est pas là dessus pour avoir un
écran bravia oled landais sur un lcd
pendant parlera plus tard avec le xperia
one qui lui par contre un écran oled
mais par contre sony mis en avant son
expertise en termes de qualité cinéma
est là il signe une fois de plus avec un
format 21/9 en disant nous on vous
ramène dans le cinéma honda cinéma dans
votre poche soit intéressant alors au
final est-ce que ce xperia 10 plus est
intéressant est ce qu'il peut me réussir
à se positionner par rapport à la
concurrence et ce qu'il peut faire
oublier plein d'autres modèles dans
cette gamme de prix sas marcoux 425
euros
je vérifie si j'ai pas dis bêtises sur
les antisèches 429 euros excusez-moi
quatre reprises y était 429 euros il ya
une énorme concurrence est très
compliqué même producteur comme sony sur
ce marché là on va faire un tour de l'ex
paria 10 plus il allait dire vous en
main ce que vous en pensez
on va commencer par le look de ce
smartphone il a un look est assez
atypique forcément avec un écran format
vienne il est très long il paraît très
long par contre il est vraiment très
sympa en prison il trouve très
facilement sa place dans ma main du fait
qu'il soit long ça tiens c'est cool
c'est pratique pour ma part ce que je
vais avoir à lui reprocher c'est cette
grande partie tout en haut ils ont caché
un petit peu avec un fond d'écran noir
mais on le voit voyez la grande bordure
ici sur le haut qui va cacher la caméra
le haut parleur et la led de
notification c'est vrai que dans les
standards actuels des grosses bordure en
haut c'est pas forcément hyper hyper
hyper hyper hyper joly après vous avez
des bordures sur le côté qui sont assez
correcte sur le bas également ça ça me
pose absolument aucun problème
vous avez néanmoins un verre corning
gorilla glass 5 à l'avant pour qu'il
soit vraiment résistant à l'arrière vous
avez un de plastique a qu'un effet
métallique qui fait le job comme ça dans
les smartphones de sony que j'ai pu
tester vous avez ici votre bouton pour
l'allumer le capteur d'empreinte
digitale est ici bouton volume c'est
très bizarre de devoir l'allumer et
ensuite déverrouiller alors bon ça
marche vous appuyez vous déverrouillez
ça roule c'est rapide
néanmoins on peut venir directement
déverrouille en appelant ce qu'attendent
empreintes digitales donc en gros le
bouton pour l'allumer sert juste à
l'éteindre c'est un peu bizarre s'en
était très bien qui nous met ici un
bouton capteurs s'en était simple y
aurait eu plus de sens mais bon ils
l'ont fait comme ça le bouton de volume
double lecteur de carte sim lecteur de
carte sim ici et lecteur de carte micro
sd pourrait monter jusqu'à 500 12 giga
de stockage maximum on a un design qui
est pas mal mais qui n'est pas
complètement fou ce qui fait vraiment la
force de ce smartphone c'est son écran
on a un écran ipes une dalle lcd de 6,5
pouces format 21/9 alors un écran qui
est plutôt pas mal
assez lumineux c'est pas le smartphone
le plus lumineux du siècle c'est pas là
où on va avoir la meilleure qualité
néanmoins vu son positionnement il est
pas mal
la grande force de ce smartphone c7
écran 21/9 là vous êtes sur une vidéo
sur youtube complètement optimisé pour
l'avenir des zooms et zoomer on est
directement sur du 21 deviennent évolué
en un format très allongée très long qui
donne l l'immersion alors là on est sur
youtube mais on l'a également sur
netflix là par exemple vous avez gravity
au format 21 9ème l'âge une image qui
est complètement optimisé la sensation
d'immersion que vous avec ça la longueur
c'est vraiment ça l'intérêt de ce
smartphone c'est d'avoir ce grand écran
format cinéma en gros vous avez un
cinéma dans votre poche même s'il
avouait que sur du lcd vous n'êtes pas
sûrs du oled on ira beaucoup plus loin
avec le xperia one dans quelques temps
mais déjà comme ça c'est franchement
hyper agréable à regarder
le revers de la médaille c'est ce que
vous rendez des vidéos sur youtube qui
sont faites pour un format 16 9
vous avez des grandes bordure sur le
côté et lorsque vous allez bien gardés
au format 21 9ème vous allez zou mais
vous allez venir vraiment croupit dans
l'image
et ça c'est tout de suite un peu dommage
parce que vous allez perdre quand même
pas mal d'informations puisque mais dans
le multimédia on va rester au niveau de
l'audio je voulais le son il ya un
[ __ ] leur qui situe ici en haut
le son est pas complètement la qualité
est pas génial
il ya du volume lorsque le volume est
très fort ça sature s'est pas
complètement génial s'est pas
complètement dix musées de ce côté là
néanmoins et comme je vous disais tout à
l'heure sony c'est un ensemble de
marques un ensemble de savoir-faire et
ils ont mis leurs technologies audio au
service de ce smartphone à savoir vous
pouvez profiter du ld assez pour une
écoute musicale complètement optimisé et
du ds jeu h x vous avez dans vos
paramètres audio vous allez dans
réglages audio et là vous pouvez venir
régler des ses-6 jeu les cochers ça vous
permet de restaurer un son haut niveau
sur les fichiers musicaux compressé pour
une qualité audio haute résolution par
contre ça ne marchera que au casque
filaire casque filaire par laurent parce
que c'est intéressant vous avez une
prise jack qui conservait sur ce
smartphone est là l'audio est vraiment
pas mal alors on va pas avoir une
puissance complètement phénoménal la
chine à fond il ya du son s'est pas
complètement dingue mais ça marche
plutôt pas mal ça ça c'est intéressant
après si vous souhaitez écouter pas
uniquement avec un casque filaire vous
avez bien évidemment du bluetooth 5.02
fut pour utiliser l'excellent casque de
sony le whh 1000 x m3 ça c'est mon petit
casse fonctionnera parfaitement bien
c'est aussi très intéressant
côté performance est pas le smartphone
le plus puissant c'est pas le smartphone
à quelqu'un vous allez faire le plus de
choses on a un stade rigole 636 c'est un
socle milieu de gamme chez qualcomm ça
marchera ça ira très bien dans le côté
ce smartphone on va pas l'utiliser pour
un smartphone de gaming hyper puissant
on va utiliser pour les applications
quotidiennes pour regarder des vidéos
pour écouter de la musique pour les sur
les réseaux sociaux
ça marchera parfaitement bien il a 4
gigas de ram il est suffisamment fluide
ça fonctionne
64 giga de stockage que pouvait monter
comme je voulais dire jusqu'à 512 gia
gaza une carte microsd que vous branchez
ici
l'autonomie quant à elle eu pas
complètement folle on a une batterie de
3000 milliampères heures vous avez
recharger en usb il sait vous n'avez pas
de la recharge rapide vous n'allez pas
leur charge et très rapidement il faudra
une bonne heure et demie pour lui mettre
une charge voire un peu plus si
affinités vous le garde
et entre une journée le journée et mis 2
jours en fonction de votre utilisation
c'est pas le smartphone le plus dingue
en termes d'autonomie
du point de vue de l'aurès on se base
sur un android 9 paille avec une
surcouche qui est franchement très
légère alors ça smartphones qui est très
grand si vous voulez utiliser à une main
il faut vous face up fait un petit
double tape là et là vous pouvez
l'utiliser à une main mais vraiment pour
venir vous dépanner c'est pas très
rapide parce qu'on n'y voit pas beaucoup
de choses mais on peut néanmoins utilisé
à une main comme ça ça peut avoir un
sens si vous avez l'autre main qu'ils
occupent et voyez vu le format de
l'écran c'est intéressant fait un petit
up deuxième fois un de bolt à plat et
vous revenez comme ça en grand écran
autre point qui est intéressant est la
petite barre latérale d'abate a de son
côté et opte pour pré vote dans latéral
avec vos applications favorites avec vos
petits raccourcis pour la navigation
fait un petit glissement son côté ici
vous naviguez entre vos applications
ouvertes c'est pratique c'est sympa ça
marche bien ça c'est aussi cool en
termes de photos vidéos ce qui est
intéressant c'est le format vous pourrez
venir shooter directement soit en 4/3
soit en 16 9e soit carrément en 21 9ème
et là vous shooter avec tout l'espace de
votre smartphone vous serez les seuls à
faire des photos en 21 deviennent les
mêmes choses pour la vidéo pourrait
venir chuté directement soit en 16 9e
soit carrément en 21/9 up mais pour
filmer en matière ne vienne vous passez
en 4k 21/9 et la voyez c'est pareil vous
serez les seuls à tourner format 21/9
cinémascope avec votre smartphone
à côté de ça le rendu est propre mais
pas complètement exceptionnel le rendu
des couleurs est assez correct ça marche
ça va la voyez ça me paraît un peu blanc
sur le dessus le point s'est pas fait
directement là c'est pas complètement
vain de la bon là le point c'est fait
mais voyez le détail est pas là c'est
pas le meilleur photophone qu'on puisse
savoir sony a fait beaucoup mieux avec
ce smartphone là c'est pareil c'est pas
génial et même un peu de bruit sur
l'image le rendu est pas gg la mise au
point est pas extraordinaire les
couleurs ne sont pas ou flâner sur la
caméra de cellfish une tête de déterré
je fais peur c'est un peu moins pire
mais bon voilà c'est pas complètement
exceptionnel il faudrait porter belle
fait avec le téléobjectif
ce qui fait qu'il faut avoir du recul
dockal recul je n'ai pas forcément
l'attend une seule à le faire envoyer je
suis un peu sur le côté c'est pas gg
c'est un peu le bazar a de ce point de
vue là pour moi c'est pas extraordinaire
parce que vous avez deux caméras
l'arrière in de 12 mégapixels c'est la
caméra principale qui ont f 1.75 une
deuxième de 8 mégapixels f 2.4 qui était
l'objectif x 2 qui vous servira pour le
mode portrait vous êtes bien évidemment
un jeu
zoom optique x 2 15 ou numérique x 5
vous avez un autofocus hybride du hdr
fois il ya pas mal de possibilités d'un
point de vue logiciel mais c'est vrai
que je suis pas emballé par le rendu des
photos qui sont faites par ce smartphone
je trouve que la proposition au niveau
de l'écran du 21 9ème est vraiment bien
le fait de pouvoir prendre des photos ou
films un 29e pourquoi pas par contre si
vous êtes un gros consommateur de
réseaux sociaux et vous voulez vraiment
des belles photos de bonne qualité
voilà je suis pas complètement persuadé
que ce soit à un smartphone excellent de
ce point de vue là après on les sent un
smartphone à 429 euros il faut raison
garder mais le problème qui avec ce
smartphone si vous laissez à la
concurrence pour le même budget vous
trouverez des smartphones qui seront
bien meilleure en termes de photos qui
ne rompt pas d'écran 21/9 c'est vraiment
là la force de ce produit n'est par
contre qu'ils seront plus rapides ils
seront meilleures photos et si
aujourd'hui un peu le problème qu'on va
retrouver avec sony c'est à dire que
sony à des savoir faire maîtrisé dans
beaucoup de domaines mais ils ont
beaucoup de mal avec l'univers du
smartphone avec une concurrence chinoise
toujours plus puissantes
ils ont du mal à séduire ils ont un
positionnement qui est vraiment axé
cinéma donc si vous voulez une bonne
expérience vidéo c'est sympa c'est pas
tout le plus enfin je crois vraiment
luxe par yoann qui on arrive à être
vraiment au dessus
mais voilà c'est un petit peu tiède et
n'oublions pas à l'avant la caméra 8
mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0
c'est un smartphone qui a du nfc de
bluetooth 5.0 ça je voulais déjà dit
qu'ils plutôt pas mal qui est
intéressant qui a une proposition de
valeur qui a le mérite d'être vraiment
différent de ce qu'on peut trouver sur
le marché
ça c'est vraiment intéressant et c'est
vraiment ce que j'aime chez sony c'est
qu'ils disent ok on va aller sur autre
chose m'a proposé aux jeux on va se
différencier et je pense qu'avec cet
écran 21/9 ils peuvent séduire les
amoureux de cinéma
ceux qui veulent une vraie expérience
21/9 sur un écran comme ça ça peut être
vraiment cool alors les usages on les
voit ça avec le multitâche
le fait de pouvoir effectivement partagé
son écran pour venir travailler ou faire
les applications multitâches ça peut
avoir un sens pour de la vidéo pour la
vidéo cinémascope 21/9 et surtout pour
venir faire des photos et des vidéos
format 21/9 c'est le seul smartphone qui
vous paraîtra de le faire en tout cas
aujourd'hui à ma connaissance c'est pas
complètement ouf
s'intéressant cette proposition de
valeur qui est vraiment différente et
rien que pour ça on peut aller saluer la
proposition de sony parce qu'ils
cherchent à faire des choses différentes
il cherche pas à faire des pâles copies
à faire la même chose que les autres ils
savent qu'ils doivent innover qui
doivent se différencier et ils vont
finir par y arriver je tourne un peu de
mal parce que l'on reprochait souvent à
sony
quelques temps un design n'était pas
terrible on a reproché pas mal de choses
à sony et sony s'est remis en question
propose des smartphones intéressant avec
le exec trois lyonnais on a eu un écran
bravia oled une excellente qualité pour
ceux qui veulent du contenu multimédia
complètement optimisé ça c'était cool et
là elle continuera dans l'idée du cinéma
cinémascope 21/9 sais pas vous ce que
vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez ce format 21/9
c'est un truc qui vous tendent qui vous
séduit qui vous séduit plus à dire est
ce que ça vous séduit oui ou non vous
marquez tout ça bien évidemment en
commentaire je vous invite à consulter
ma playlist qui vous parlera de tous les
smartphones du moment et croyez moi il y
en a beaucoup et il y en aura encore
beaucoup qui vont arriver d'ici quelques
temps d'ici là je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous soyez sages ciao